a holy war breaks out after texas bans
abortion after the detection of fetal
heartbeat the biden administration
continues to declare its own heroism
while telling americans that the taliban
might be our friends now and don lemon
says if you're unvaccinated don't go to
the hospital if you're sick i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first here is a reminder
you're spending way too much on your
cell phone bill so you think you have to
pay one of these giant cell phone
providers
enormous sums of money for decent
coverage and you think that because you
know you look at their advertising and
they seem really really big right i mean
you're driving around town and you see
there's the att store there's a verizon
store well here's the thing of that
advertising all those brick and mortar
stores they cost a lot of money which
means that you're paying for all of that
overhead or you could just get the same
exact coverage because you could be
using the exact same cell towers as one
of the big networks via pure talk usa
with pure talk because they're not
spending all that money you are being
saved 800 a year if you're the average
family without having to sacrifice the
coverage you can keep your phone you can
keep your number or you can get huge
discounts on the latest iphones and
androids i got the iphone 12. and let me
just make this clear you are getting the
exact same coverage as one of the big
cell phone networks these guys invest a
fortune into making sure you have the
latest technology they pass that entire
savings on to you get unlimited talk
text and six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month or if you still want
unlimited data they have that plan as
well and it's still way cheaper than
whatever you would get with one of the
big cell phone providers just style
pound 250 say ben shapiro you will save
50 off your very first month that's
pounds 2 5 0 say ben shapiro pure talk
is simply smarter wireless already so
the big news of the day
is of course that the supreme court has
not immediately enjoined a texas state
law that effectively prevents abortion
after six weeks of pregnancy
and the reason the supreme court did
this is because of procedural mechanics
here so basically the supreme court
ruled
and the ruling was it was a five to four
ruling with of course chief justice
roberts joining the dissenters it was
the the republican appointees on one
side and then roberts with the liberals
on the other and the basic scheme of the
texas law is why the law was not
immediately taken up by the supreme
court so normally in order for you to
have a a lawsuit that is taken up by an
appeals court or taken up by the supreme
court you have to have somebody to sue
right just because you see something
wrong in life does not mean that you get
to sue and the person that you sue has
to be the right person and if you're
suing over a law presumably if you sue
for example the the person who is
enforcing the law that person has to
have the power to enforce the law so for
example in in roe versus wade it was an
official of government who was being
sued in roe versus way because it was
that person's responsibility to enforce
the law so that person ends up as the
defendant this is usually the case when
you have a case that's appealed to the
supreme court and it has to do with the
law that is being enforced by the state
usually
there's some official whose name you
don't know who ends up as the defendant
in that particular lawsuit well texas
found a way around this at least for the
moment it's sort of a creative way
around this the way that they wrote the
law it is not that the texas state
government is going to be enforcing the
law it's not like somebody comes to your
door and takes you off to jail if you
participate in in the abortion process
at 12 weeks of pregnancy instead what
the texas state law basically did is it
created a private right of action
the private right of action essentially
allows anyone to sue a person in court
who has participated in the facilitation
of an abortion according to politico
individuals found to have violated that
law would have to pay ten thousand
dollars to the person who successfully
brings such a lawsuit right so it's
almost sort of a private bounty in other
words so let's say that there's a woman
who wants an abortion
i know her abortion doctor is providing
her an abortion i can sue the abortion
doctor for providing her an abortion at
ten weeks and then he has to pay me ten
thousand dollars for his violation of
the law
according to politico anti-abortion
groups in the states such as texas
rights life have in recent weeks set up
tip lines for people to anonymously
report violators ahead of the law's
implementation earlier on tuesday a
federal district court issued a
temporary restraining order
barring the group from filing suits
against a small group of individuals and
organizations that assist patients in
obtaining an abortion but both sides of
the case acknowledge the order is very
narrow and the anti-abortion group said
it still plans to solicit tips and bring
lawsuits against abortion providers now
that the courts have given a green light
to the law's implementation so the
supreme court majority does not say
whether the law is constitutional they
just say that it is not clear whether
they can take up the case because
there's nobody to sue yet right nobody
has actually brought a lawsuit along
these lines as of yet so the supreme
court found
to prevail in an application for a stay
or an injunction an applicant must carry
the burden of making a strong showing
that is likely to succeed on the merits
and that will be irrevocably injured
absent to stay and that the balance of
equity favors it and that it stays
consistent with the public interest the
applicants now before us have very
serious questions regarding the
constitutionality of the texas law at
issue but their application also
presents complex and novel antecedent
procedural questions on which they have
not carried their burden so this is the
supreme court saying listen we might not
strike down roe versus wade we might in
fact strike down this law but first you
have to go through the actual procedure
of somebody having been grievously
harmed by a private actor in this
particular way because this lawsuit was
again directed at a person austin reeve
jackson who's a judge
it's directed at a person who actually
does not have the power to even enforce
the law per se
so says the majority
federal courts enjoy the power to enjoin
individuals tasked with enforcing laws
not the laws themselves it is unclear
whether the name defendants in this
lawsuit can or will seek to enforce the
texas law against the applicants in a
manner that might permit our
intervention the state has represented
that neither it nor its executive
employees possess the authority to
enforce the texas law either directly or
indirectly nor is it clear whether under
existing precedent this court can issue
an injunction against state judges asked
to decide a lawsuit under texas law
which is the person who was sued in this
particular case finally the sole private
citizen responded before us has filed an
affidavit stating he has no present
intention to enforce the law in light of
such issues we can't say the applicants
have met their burden to prevail in an
injunction or stay application okay then
they were to the descents and then it
descends justice roberts didn't say that
he would vote to uphold roe versus way
he just said that he put an injunction
on the law pending some sort of
resolution of the underlying issues
there's the procedural issues and then
there's the underlying issue which is
really the one at the heart of the case
which is is it constitutional to pass a
law that bars abortion after weak sex
now
look from a from a pure constitutional
perspective the answer of course is it's
fully constitutional for the vast
majority of america's history there
abortion laws in virtually every state
and obviously there is no right to an
abortion in the constitution of the
united states you can't point to it you
can't point to anything that points to
it it is emanations and penumbras and an
idiotic supreme court majority in roe
versus wade that literally created a
right to abortion out of whole cloth i
mean he's just created fully and just
sits there like a like a turd at the
bottom of the toilet bowl that's how bad
that decision it is a terrible decision
even people who are advocates of
abortion generally recognize that roe
versus wade is not a good legal decision
they just like the outcome
okay so as a matter of just what's in
the constitution on the underlying issue
the answer is of course texas can pass
this law and california can also pass a
law that allows abortion up till a
particular point
maybe beyond depending on exactly what
exactly california is doing and whether
the 14th amendment and the and the due
process clause and the equal protection
clause applies to the unborn right
there's a strong pro-life case that the
equal protection clause right that
everyone is entitled to equal protection
of the law so far as life liberty and uh
and due process for example that those
that should include the unborn right
this is the pro-life case that if you
are a baby in the womb you don't get to
be killed just because you're a baby in
the womb you're an independent human
life are protected by the constitution
of the united states but putting that
aside if you if that is not the argument
that is going to be accepted by the
supreme court for example which it seems
would be unlikely if that's not going to
be the argument accepted by the supreme
court the overturning of roe vs wade
would not lead to a vast national ban on
abortion it would lead to significant
restrictions in places like texas places
like georgia places like florida it
would lead to no restrictions in places
like california because it would just
get kicked back to the states that was
the situation before roe versus wade
there were very few restrictions on
abortion in blue states and there were
lots of restrictions on abortion in red
states
okay so chief justice roberts says you
know i'm not going to even tell you how
i'm voting on the underlying issue by
the way the majority said the same thing
here roberts just says that he would
enjoin it anyway so robert says the
statutory scheme before the court is not
only unusual but unprecedented the
legislature has imposed a prohibition on
abortions after roughly six weeks and
then essentially delegated enforcement
of that prohibition to the populace at
large the desired consequence appears to
be to insulate the state from
responsibility for implementing and
enforcing the regulatory regime the
state defendants argue they cannot be
restrained from enforcing their rules
because they're not enforcing them in
the first place i would grant
preliminary relief to preserve the
status quo ante before the law went into
effect so that the courts may consider
whether a state can avoid responsibility
for its laws in such a manner
defendants argue existing doctrines
preclude judicial intervention and they
may be correct
but the consequences of approving the
state action both in this particular
case and as a model for action in other
areas council at least preliminary
judicial consideration before the
program devised by the state takes
effect so roberts is fully admitting in
his own dissent here that defendants may
be right that they are allowed to to
avoid culpability here because they're
not the actual defendants but justice
roberts says i'm going to intervene
anyway because i prefer the status quo
ante which is pure roberts right roberts
is mostly interested in preserving what
he perceives as judicial legitimacy at
the expense of actual judicial accuracy
and this is why he'll rewrite the
obamacare law in order to ensure that
obamacare remains the law of the land
despite the fact that it clearly
violates constitutional provisions and
separation of powers
right because justice roberts is always
thinking of the legitimacy of the by the
way because he thinks like this he's
completely undermined the legitimacy of
the institution it turns out the only
way to uphold the legitimacy of your
institution is to strictly interpret the
rules under which we are all supposed to
live so that there is predictability to
those rules you're not supposed to be
thinking with your finger in the wind
how do i best uphold the legitimacy of
my institution that is what undercuts
your legitimacy at least it's true as a
human being as well if you're constantly
vacillating because you're trying to
please people people don't like you as
much people think you're illegitimate
people don't trust you okay this is
certainly true when it comes to
institutions which is why justice
roberts is actually a terrible terrible
justice in any case
he continues i would accordingly
preclude enforcement of sb8 by the
respondents to afford the district court
and the court of appeals the opportunity
to consider the propriety of judicial
action and preliminary relief pending
consideration of the plaintiff's claims
because basically his his argument is
that this
it upsets life too much if we don't if
we don't intervene it upsets life too
much then there are the actual liberals
on the court and their defense is
basically we love abortion and abortions
in the constitution and this is a bad
law and so we should strike down the law
forget about the procedure the law needs
to go because the reality is that
imminent and serious harm are on their
way and we need to we need to make sure
that the quote-unquote right to abortion
is preserved right this is the descent
there's one from justice breyer there's
another one from justice sotomayor
sotomayor of course is the most uh vocal
ardent and uh and screedlike uh she
writes the most screeds on the left of
the court she sort of replaced justice
ginsburg in that respect she says the
court's order is stunning presented with
an application to enjoy in a flagrantly
unconstitutional law engineered to
prohibit women from exercising their
constitutional rights and evade judicial
scrutiny a majority of justices have
opted to bury their heads in the sand
okay it's not flagrantly
unconstitutional roe versus wade is
flagrantly anti-constitutional it is a
made-up law out of whole cloth pulled
directly from the colons of the justices
in that case particularly harry blackman
but
she says this is blatantly
unconstitutional which is a laugh since
her actual care about the constitution
is basically zero says last night the
court silently acquiesced in a state's
enactment of a law that flowed to nearly
50 years of federal precedence wow 50
years of bad federal judicial precedent
has been overturned well somebody
sounded the alarm as it turns out the
court has routinely done that in cases
where they've made bad mistakes before
namely plessy versus ferguson or dred
scott
she says today the court belatedly
explains it declined to grant relief
because of procedural complexities of
the state's own invention because the
court's failure to act rewards tactics
designed to avoid judicial review and
inflicts significant harm on the
applicants and on women seeking abortion
in texas i dissent
wow okay so that is where things stand
now
a lot of people in the media are reading
this as though the supreme court of the
united states is now going to knock down
rovers away i have serious doubts
whether the supreme court of the united
states is going to knock down rovers
away i think what they may do is rewrite
the planned parenthood versus casey
standard
which is a really really bad standard
and i'll explain what that means in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact you need a great night's sleep now
i famously have said that i sleep on a
mattress made of money but i'll be
honest with you my mattress isn't
actually made of money it's just the
best mattress money can buy i'm talking
about helix sleep helix sleep has a quiz
that takes just two minutes to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you why would you buy a mattress made
for someone else with helix you're
getting a mattress that you know will be
perfect for the way you sleep everybody
is unique helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium and
firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
mattresses great for spinal alignment to
prevent morning aches and pains even a
helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers so if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress you're matched to the mattress
comes right to your door shipped for
free you don't ever need to go to a
mattress store again helix has financing
options and flexible payment plans so a
great night's sleep is never far away
they even have a special financing offer
where you can get your own helix the
number one rated mattress in america for
less than a buck a day so if you buy a
queen standard mattress or even treat
yourself and get deluxe model you can
qualify to pay less than 28 bucks a
month over 36 months it's a limited time
offer it ends september 19th so if
you've been wanting to upgrade your
sleep now is a fabulous time to do it
head on over to helixsleep.com they've
got a 10 year warranty get to tried out
for 100 nights risk-free so you really
have nothing to lose check them out
right now we have a helix sleep mattress
we love it helix is offering up to 200
bucks off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners best deal
of the year helix sleep.com
that's helixleep.com
ben alrighty so
the actual standard that may be curbed
here is the so-called undo burden
standard under planned parenthood versus
casey so the roe vs wade decision sets
up this ridiculous anti-scientific
trimester system right where the idea is
that you could have some restrictions in
the last trimester maybe a few
restrictions in the second trimester and
no restrictions in the first trimester
and then it sets up a standard of
viability and it says well until the
baby's viable you can basically do what
you want
none of this is in the constitution of
course it's absurd it's just made up
completely then
in the early 90s there's a case written
by sandra day o'connor and anthony
kennedy and that whole clan and the the
basic
idea of the case is that
the woman must never be unduly burdened
right she can't be that is the undue
burden standard
that a woman cannot
have to face down in order that has the
purpose or effect of placing a
substantial obstacle in the path of a
woman seeking the abortion of a
non-viable fetus okay and it's a mess i
mean that decision is a complete
absolute mask there's a plurality
decision okay so majority found that
that a particular law was
unconstitutional
four justices wrote or joined opinions
saying roe vs white should have been
struck down two justices wrote opinions
favoring the preservation of a higher
standard of review of review for
abortion restrictions it's a complete
mess right it's it's just a complete and
utter just bleep show
no question
the undue burden standard is what ends
up emerging from this right you can't
put an undue burden on a woman's right
or ability to get an abortion now the
question is that's really vague what
actually constitutes an undue burden
where where does that come from
okay so the court has been very unclear
about this sometimes they'll say that
something is an undue burden sometimes
they'll say it's not an undue burden
again the notion that an abortion is a
is a right to begin with is patently
crazy i mean that is there's nothing in
the constitution that guarantees such a
right there's nothing in natural law
that guarantees such a right they're
like it's where does this right come
from it basically came full blown from
the heads of a bunch of left-leaning
justices on the supreme court
but
it has now become a rote part of sort of
leftist theology and it really is of
theology at this point that abortion is
an inerrant good
abortion is itself excellent
and so you see people on the left
consistently making this argument
now i just want to point out that by six
weeks of pregnancy the baby is already
starting to develop like a lot okay like
the levels of development at this point
in time are pretty high so you keep
hearing from people well you know most
women don't know that they're even
pregnant by week six of the pregnancy
well i mean they've already missed a
period so there's that but beyond that
there actually is some pretty
significant development like the notion
that this is just a cluster of
undifferentiated cells at this point is
just not true
according to the mayo clinic right which
is not a right-wing site last i checked
they say week six the neural tube closes
growth is rapid this week just four
weeks after conception the neural tube
along your baby's back is closing the
baby's brain and spinal cord will
develop from the neural tube the heart
and other organs are also starting to
form and the heart begins to beat this
according to mayo clinic now you look
here from people on the left well it's
not really the heart because the entire
heart hasn't been developed yet it's
just the it's it's the poles that will
become the heart that are firing
electrical signals
okay and
like really so
is necessary to the formation of the
eyes and ears develop small buds appear
that will soon become arms your baby's
body begins to take on a c-shaped
curvature in week seven the baby's head
develops
the baby's brain and face are growing
depressions that eventually give rise to
nostrils become visible the beginnings
of the retinas form lower limb buds that
will become legs appear the arm buds
that sprouted last week now take on the
shape of paddles week eight you've
already got a nose for the baby the
fingers have begun to form small
swellings outlined
outlining the future shell-shaped parts
of your baby's ears develop the eyes
become obvious the upper lip and nose
have formed the trunk and neck begin to
straighten again we are eight weeks in
according to the left you should be able
to abort like pretty much all the way up
to birth there are no limiting
principles for the left but fetal
development is extraordinarily rapid
and pretty well developed certainly by
the time you hit the first trimester for
sure
okay but according to the left this is
just texas is evil and texas is terrible
and texas is a
disaster and there's an article after
article about this gayle collins says
texas is trying to overturn roe versus
wade all by itself
she says texas and of course you get the
obligatory
you get
this just amuses me you get the
obligatory photo of the women in the
handmaid's tale outfits
okay now just quick note you can get an
abortion pretty much anywhere in the
country that ain't texas also quick note
the the woman in the photo is wearing a
a pride progress face mask a transgender
rights face mask with a gay
pride flag rainbow flag over her face in
the new york times photo that has been
chosen
and um this has become part of the
broader left-wing rubric where they just
create mad libs that don't make any
sense when it comes to these issues
right so what they like to say the
original left-wing argument was safe
legal and rare right it's sad but it's
necessary in some cases we'd like to
make those cases less necessary but you
know where a woman is having a really
tough time we can't we can't burden her
he has a bad argument but at least had
some semblance of morality attached to
it then we went from safe legal and rare
to abortion is the greatest thing that
ever happened and now we've moved all
the way to abortion is a woke issue that
affects the intersectional coalition
which is like the weakest pro-abortion
argument of all at least the secondary
argument that a woman needs to abort her
baby so she can be successful in her
career which is sort of the argument
you'll see made routinely by
pro-abortion advocates
at least that argument
acknowledges the the logical consistency
of i need to kill this baby so that i
can get the promotion that's you know
pretty cruel and terrible but at least
it acknowledges it
when it gets enmeshed in the entire
intersectional woke rhetoric it makes no
sense at all it just starts to be
self-contradictory and very silly right
when you're declaring that men can be
women and it's very difficult to explain
how this is a woman's right issue when
you're when you're calling women
pregnant people
very difficult to explain why this is a
quote-unquote women's issue as opposed
to just you know a broad issue that
affects both women and men all the rest
my favorite line of this and this is why
i point out the the gay pride flag this
person is wearing while wearing the
handmaid's tail outfit
is again once it gets enmeshed in the in
the left-wing mad lib it starts to make
no sense so corey bush this is just a
great example of this she tweets out
yesterday the congresswoman from
missouri the black lives matter
congresswoman from missouri says i'm
thinking about the black brown
low-income queer and young folks in
texas the folks this abortion healthcare
ban will disproportionately harm
wealthy white folks will have the means
to access abortion care our communities
won't okay so one of the arguments that
is consistently made by people on the
left is that black and brown women need
to have lots of abortions it is
incumbent upon them we need to protect
their right to kill babies in the womb
because and to disproportionately kill
babies in the womb now you know who's
during that white supremacists they are
very happy to see black and brown babies
die in the womb
and there are more black babies every
year who are aborted in new york city
and are born in new york city
and you can hear the white supremacist
cheering
the notion that it is it is an inherent
good
for black and brown women to
disproportionately kill their unborn
babies is very weird but put that one
aside i want to focus in on this just
shows what a ma i keep saying mad lib
because it really is it makes no
internal sense corey bush here saying
i'm thinking about the queer people
who are disproportionately affected by
an abortion map i'm gonna need an
explainer on this one
truly i'm gonna need an explainer on why
lesbians are disproportionately affected
by an abortion ban
are lesbians accidentally getting
pregnant at a now-sized rate
how about like gay people and
transgender people
is that happening a lot
really is it disproportionately
affecting the queer
i'm gonna need some sort of
understanding of how that works
according to corey bush
but it doesn't it doesn't matter again
everything they don't like is about
inequity
because they don't want to get to the
root of the issue which is that they are
fine with killing the unborn right that
really is what it is some people are
honest enough to do it mostly it's
euphemisms so the new euphemisms of the
day are not women's rights it's not safe
legal and rare the new euphemism of the
day is it's inequitable inequitable and
it affects all the same people that
every inequitable policy affects
including people who are gay who are not
getting pregnant accidentally because
that's not physically possible if you
are engaged in homosexual activity
that's not how any of this works
so i just i found that hilarious and
self-contradictory but
again none of this has to make any sense
we'll get some more of it in just one
second first
let's talk about the equity you have in
your home right that is your most
valuable property for sure is your home
how much equity do you have in there
fifty thousand hundred thousand bucks
more cyber crime experts are alerting
homeowners the more equity you have the
greater the chance foreign and domestic
criminals will come after you home title
theft is one of the fastest growing
crimes in fact home title lock america's
leader in home title protection is
alerting homeowners they could already
be a victim and not know it here's how
it goes down first cyber thieves search
hundreds of public databases for high
equity homes next they pull your home's
online title forward your signature
stating you sold your home and take out
loans using your equity you're not
covered by insurance your bank or common
identity theft program protect your most
valuable asset register your address now
to see if you're already a victim
receive the complete title history of
your home it's 100 value free
go to home title lock dot com again
that's home title lock dot com go check
them out right now see if you're already
a victim
you get a title history of your house
it's a 100 value you get it for free
when you go to home title lock.com and
protect your most valuable asset you
don't want to leave that value just
lying out there for somebody to grab
home title lock.com so again the the
left is fighting mad about this because
abortion has now become a sacrament and
now it's become a sacrament in the
higher woke cataclys
catechism which is very strange okay
hillary clinton is tweeting out about
this as well she says under the cover of
darkness by choosing to do nothing the
supreme court allowed an
unconstitutional abortion ban in texas
to go into effect last night their
decision doesn't change the fact that
reproductive rights are human rights
we'll fight for them by the way
the euphemisms the euphemisms if you
just read that out loud but instead of
reproductive rights you just said
killing the unborn in the womb you'd
realize how self-contradictory and silly
this is right the decision doesn't
change the fact that killing unborn
humans in the womb is a human right
i feel like that doesn't make sense i
feel like that contradicts itself
okay but again the underlying issue here
is one where the left is not winning
they know they're not winning and so
they have to euphemism it up it's all
euphemisms
it's euphemisms and equity talk here's
wendy davis doing the same exact thing
so this is a law that's going to hit as
is the case so many times
women who are lower income
women of color
and it's going to further and deepen the
systemic racism and the impacts of so
many systems in our state
it's amazing the left is actually making
its own agenda less popular by using the
equity talk instead of saying that this
damages women because women need the
right to abortion broadly instead they
have to go to this hurts black brown low
income queer women like
what are you doing i mean you want to do
it go for it you really want to say that
this forward systemic racism so in other
words telling
everybody white
black
brown you can't kill your baby in the
womb
saying that
forward systemic racism because if it
were not for that systemic racism more
black babies would be born
hot take coming in hot right there
and wendy davis the fact that she still
trotted out as a legit figure because
she once made a long speech on the floor
of the texas state legislature while
wearing pink sneakers is astonishing to
me the level the levels of
accomplishment you need in order to
achieve fame in the society uh are not
particularly high speaking of which
jeffrey toobin who is most famous for
masturbating on camera in front of his
work colleagues he wrote quote midnight
in austin for the first time since 1973
a state has banned abortion the great
conservative legal project has succeeded
r.i.p hashtag rov versus wade now first
of all his mouth to god's ears um but
second of all um roe versus wade has not
yet been overturned
also
jeffrey toobin commenting on this
i understand there's some people i will
say at least jeffrey hooven has a stake
in it right jeffrey tubin famously
impregnated the daughter of one of his
friends and then tried to pressure her
to have an abortion and then tried to
avoid his paternity payments so he feels
like a really good source on this sort
of thing by the way cnn broadband like
four or five times yesterday to talk
about this because the media have no
shame whatsoever but they're very
objective very journalism so much
journalism in fact speaking of the
journalism chris cuomo tweeted out a
graphic of carlos chapman a law
professor at washington and lee
university from occupy democrats nothing
says journalism
like tweeting out graphics from occupied
democrats
this woman said quote if a fetus is a
person it's six weeks pregnant is that
when the child support starts okay so
first of all sure
i'm cool with that you gotta i don't
have a problem with that in fact utah i
believe passed a law exactly along those
lines saying that when a woman is
pregnant men have to start paying child
support also quote is that also when you
can't support the mother because she's
carrying a u.s citizen so there are some
pretty significant questions about
whether birthright citizenship is even a
thing can i ensure a six weeks six-week
fetus and collect if i miscarry
i mean
you you you might be able to why not
just figuring if we're going there we
should go all in so this is one of my
favorite kinds of arguments that the
left makes which is they'll say well if
a fetus is a person will you do all
these things okay and if i say yes are
you now going to acknowledge if fetus is
a person or are you just
being an idiot are you just playing
stupid semantic word games chris cuomo
fond of stupid semantic board games and
also covering for his uh lying cheating
and horrifying brother
again so much journalism happening just
hot sticky journalism getting everywhere
over at the cnn studios speaking of
which riva martin on cnn she she decided
to link the pro-life position to not
wanting to wear masks
now last i checked
if i don't wear mask and you have the
capacity to protect yourself that is not
the same thing as me putting a needle
into a woman and uh and poisoning the
fetus inside and then and then cutting
them up in the womb and sucking the baby
in the sink like i i don't really see
the resemblance i'll be honest with you
i'm vaccinated and um if you get a
transmissible disease from me that you
could have protected yourself from i
don't see exactly how there's any
relationship between that and you
forcibly killing a child but
admit maybe maybe she's just too
sophisticated for me here
at this moment it is not clear to me
that women will be able to continue to
make reproductive uh you know choices
about their bodies because men primarily
men but legislative legislatures like
those in texas and other states uh have
decided that they know better as it
relates to what women should be able to
do with respect to their body and as
lara said that the hypocrisy is just
nauseating can't uh you know wear a mask
but you can decide that a woman can't
make choices about her body uh this is a
wake-up call for women and men all over
this country
yeah that's that's that's a good time by
the way it works in reverse as well if
you believe that women ought to have
pure choice over their body why are you
telling them there need to be vaccine
mandates and mass mandates and i notice
there's some inconsistency there from
the left and then of course there's the
bottom line call here which is of course
that american conservatives are like the
taliban because they want to protect
unborn life they have amy siskind who is
a radical activist tweeting out psy
texas taliban and then a and then a
cartoon from mike lukovich from the
atlanta journal constitution who is of
course of the radical left saying
it's a picture of two women in full
burqa uh
living under the taliban saying pray for
texas women
yes i'm sure that that's yes you're
right a woman living in texas but by the
way i've noticed that there are a few
ways that you don't need to um get
pregnant that are available to women
throughout american life
and that abortion is actually not
supposed to be a form of birth control
that again this is this is the shift in
the democratic argument it used to be
safe legal and rare because the idea was
there might be some terrible
circumstances where the baby has some
sort of deep malformation where you
don't want to live with that i think
that's immoral but that is the argument
democrats were making or the kid has
down syndrome people are literally
making that argument online today you
know how many down syndrome babies will
be born in texas now it's like well yeah
i mean better than killing them it turns
out um but
they move from that argument real fast
to
you're the taliban if you wish for women
to use other forms of birth control as
opposed to this
abortion has become a sacrament it's the
only thing they can explain the the true
abiding fervor for abortion
and recognize for a second that even
margaret sanger the founder of planned
parenthood was not a fan of abortion she
thought that abortion was great evil
which is why she was in favor of
contraception
okay so that is where things stand do i
think that this is going to end with the
overturning of roe vs wade i have
significant doubt that it will i think
it might result in the paring back of
planned parenthood versus casey and the
succeeding line of cases um but i think
that is much more likely than the
complete overturning of roe versus wade
but the panic uh is worth the price of
admission from the left at this point
and second we'll get to the latest on
afghanistan first let us talk about the
fact that you don't need to go to the
post office like ever post office is
great they do a lot of wonderful things
but you don't want to schlep your stuff
over to the post office and then you
wait in line for long you can just do
all of that from home or the office
we've been doing that for years
over here at daily wire from stamps.com
with stamps.com you can skip the trips
to the post office you can save on
postage mail and chip anytime anywhere
right from your computer send letters
ship packages pay less a lot less with
discounted rates from usps and ups as
well
stamps.com saves us thousands of hours
and tons of money every single year and
again the deals that you're getting from
stamps.com are really really good like
40 off usps and up to 66 off ups
shipping rates they've got their switch
and save features so you can quickly
compare carriers and find the best rates
every single time so stop wasting time
going to the post office go to
stamps.com instead there's no risk with
my promo code shapiro you get a special
offer it includes a four-week trial plus
free postage and digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage type in
shapiro that's stamps.com promo code
shapirostamps.com
never go to the post office again okay
we'll get to everything afghanistan in
just one second because it turns out
that shock of shocks joe biden is a damn
liar first once a month your favorite
daily wire hose come together we have
some whiskey smoke a few stickers i
don't know either of those things but
everybody else does have a lively
conversation about the state of the
world and usually everything that's
wrong with it maybe yell at each other a
little bit and we re-fight the
reformation between michael knowles and
jeremy boring pretty much every every
time well now if you really love that
sort of stuff you can now see it live
because instead of just tuning in from
your home you'll be able to go to see us
on stage at the famous ryman auditorium
in nashville doing what we do best
making sense and arguing with one
another and all getting annoyed at
knowles and making jokes about how
andrew clavin is soon to die so join me
candace owens jeremy boring michael
knowles matt walsh and clavin for a
backstage like never before we have a
very special offer it's pretty cool
starting at 11 a.m eastern today daily
wire members get first dibs to buy
tickets ahead of general admission so if
you're a member you've got a leg up
check your email for an exclusive code
you can use to pre-order your ticket
once you have your code pre-purchase
your tickets ahead of everybody else at
dailywire.com
ryman if you're not a member you can
join today at dailywire.com subscribe do
it like right now and you can still get
your choice of seats or you can wait
just like all of the other peons until
the tickets go on sale everywhere
tomorrow friday september 3rd check your
email make sure you don't miss out
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty meanwhile the afghanistan
situation continues to fall completely
apart
it is a disaster area but the good news
is that the biden administration they
their
their arm has has grown to three feet
long so that they can really tap
themselves on back pat themselves on the
back uh stroke themselves in every way
possible tuban all over themselves uh
they can they can do all of these things
now physically they've pretzeled
themselves in order to make all of this
happen ron klein who's the shadow
president for joe biden who spends all
day on twitter retweeting things i mean
he's basically like trump on twitter he
uh he
he said yesterday that the afghan
pull-out was handled as well as humanly
possible
it's easy to second-guess but let's just
be clear america was in this war for 20
years and i think any effort to unwind
that any effort to bring our troops out
any effort to end our military presence
in afghanistan was going to be filled
with
heartbreaking scenes and difficulties
and i think the biden administration has
managed that as well as it can be
managed under the circumstances we were
placed in
um the circumstances you placed
yourselves in it was handled as well as
could be managed and then lloyd austin
the secretary of defense he came out he
said this was historic we're so good at
this man we are so good at this so a few
things one this is not dunkirk okay
we're doing this under cover of night
with the nazis looking down at british
troops and then a flotilla of small
fishing boats being sent across the
english channel this was planes going in
and out of a runway under no fire that's
what this was and you guys failing to
facilitate that and getting american
troops killed that's what this was
here's lloyd austin again just keep just
keep stroking yourself man just keep
keep doing it
now we have just concluded the largest
air evacuation of civilians in american
history
it was heroic
it was historic
and i hope that all americans will unite
to thank our service members for their
courage and their compassion
they were operating in an
immensely dangerous and dynamic
environment
but our troops were tireless
fearless
and selfless
my favorite is when he says things like
this is the biggest evacuation in
american history aren't we good at this
there wouldn't have been an evacuation
necessary if you hadn't pursued an
entirely garbage policy by the way when
people say things like this is
unprecedented dunkirk involved 340 000
troops being evacuated from the french
coastline
so actually this is actually it's pretty
well historically precedented in the
aftermath of the 1948 war establishing
the state of israel some eight hundred
thousand people their journeys from arab
lands to israel jews had been expelled
that was facilitated right so no large
population in the in the aftermath of
the saddam hussein kuwait war there were
huge population transfers that were
facilitated so no this is not
unprecedented no it's not particularly
logistically impressive from the
secretary of defense's perspective and
yes our people on the ground are brave
and heroic but our leadership is just
garbage all the way through meanwhile i
am amazed at the spectacle of the biden
administration saying that you know
people should have gotten out early we
were telling them they needed to get out
earlier and then they didn't get out
earlier so if they got stuck it's really
their own fault there's only one problem
with that which is that joe biden is a
damn liar you'll remember in july he
said the government was not going to
fall now he's like well we were telling
people back in march they should leave
really in july you were saying the
government wasn't going to fall not only
that in july the president of the united
states called up the the
then afghan president ashraf ghani
and some of the transcript has now been
leaked this was july 23rd
and he was telling gani to lie to
everybody and say that everything was
hunky-dory how are you expecting people
to take you seriously when you are
actively encouraging the president of
afghanistan to lie about the situation
being just fine
there's only one reason that joe biden
wanted that the one reason that joe
biden wanted that is to shore up his own
domestic political failures
he didn't want people to know that
things were collapsing that quickly
because then everybody would be like
whoa maybe it was a bad idea to announce
to your mortal enemy the taliban what
date you were going to leave how you
were going to leave and then withdraw
all air support
here's what biden said to ghani it's
unbelievable remember donald trump was
impeached over ukraine phone call
there's some problems with that phone
call nothing to me approaching the level
of the president of the united states
calling up the afghan president and
telling him to overtly lie to the world
about the military situation on the
ground in
afghanistan here is what biden said
quote
you know i'm a moment late but i mean it
sincerely hey look i want to make it
clear i'm not a military man any more
than you are but i have been meeting
with our pentagon folks and our national
security people as you have been with
ours and yours and as you know and as i
need not tell you the perception around
the world and in parts of afghanistan i
believe is that things aren't going well
in terms of the fight against the
taliban and there is a need whether it
is true or not there is a need to
project a different picture
there is a need to project a different
picture
i mean like that's amazing he's telling
him overtly to lie by the way he also
lied to him this way he said we're gonna
continue to make sure your air force is
capable of continuing to fly and provide
air support this is what he told ghani
in july lie he did not continue to
provide air support he he withdrew all
military contractors from the country
he said in addition to that we're going
to continue to fight hard diplomatically
politically economically make sure your
government not only survives but is
sustained and grows because it is
clearly in the interest of the f of the
people of afghanistan that you succeed
and that you lead
i find you a brilliant and honorable man
but the perception is that things are
falling apart
and uh we need that perception to change
it's not about the reality on the ground
changing ghani replied said mr president
we're facing a full-scale invasion
composed of taliban full pakistani
planning logistical support at least at
10 to 15 000 international terrorists
predominantly pakistanis thrown into
this so this so that dimension needs to
be taken account of
he said what is crucial right this is
ghani speaking to biden and there's a
leaked transcript of a phone call the
biden will not be impeached over what is
crucial is that close air support and if
i could make a request if your
assistance particularly to our air force
be front loaded because what we need at
this moment there was a very heavy
reliance on air power we have
prioritized that if it could be at all
front loaded we will greatly appreciate
it
okay so and and biden didn't do any of
that and then he said look close air
support works only if there is a
military strategy on the ground to
support so he overtly
he said we're going to give you the air
support and governor's like okay well
we'd like to see it he's like well
you're not getting it
and then he says well why didn't people
leave earlier while i was encouraging
the president what a what a
what a dishonest piece of work the
president of the united states is
okay so jen saki was asked specifically
about this pathetic phone call from the
president of the united states urging
the afghan president to lie to the
general public while withdrawing close
air support and uh and she of course
dodged the question i'll circle back
around
there's some reporting that we like to
confirm regarding a
call in june in july rather between
president biden and former afghanistan
president ghani is that accurate can you
tell us a little bit more about that
well i'm not going to get into private
diplomatic conversations or leaked
transcripts of phone calls was the
president in any way pushing a false
narrative in that call with the afghan
president i think it's pretty clear
again i'm not going to go into details
of a private conversation
oh you're not going to go into details
it's not private anymore it's right out
there are you saying it's not true
because we've seen it
so so her play is
this thing that was unclass that was
classified has now been leaked the
entire american public can see it it's
on the headline of every major newspaper
in the world
i won't comment because it was
classified and now you've all read it
weird i noticed that she had no problem
speaking repeatedly about things like
the seal dossier for four years
meanwhile we are learning that a
majority of afghans who had worked for
the us military and applied for special
immigrant visas had not been
successfully evacuated and remained in
afghanistan a senior state department
official said it appeared that a
majority
a majority are still there
according to the senior official i don't
have an estimate for you on the number
of sivs and family members who are still
there i would say it's the majority of
them just based on anecdotal information
about the populations we were able to
support
state department spokesperson ned price
said that of about 31 000 people
evacuated from afghanistan to the united
states between august 17th and august
31st roughly 23 000 afghan allies and
family members considered at risk by the
taliban the effort was hampered by the
unpredictable role of the taliban
stationed along routes into the airport
the official said the taliban cooperated
in some cases but in other cases blocked
afghan nationals from proceeding to the
airport according to the official
on tuesday based on the initial figures
then available from the pentagon nbc
news reported 8 500 afghan allies had
been evacuated it was not clear if all
of those 8 500 were applicants for sivs
or other expedited visas on wednesday
the pentagon then released new figures
saying that about 20 thousand afghans
had arrived at eight military bases in
the united states
he said they're also another forty
thousand afghan evacuees but did not
provide a breakdown on how many of these
people were actually screened who these
people were were they sivs were they
translators basically what happened is
that at the very beginning they just
loaded people on planes and took them
they didn't screen any of them that's
that's probably what was happening at
the very beginning
the reason i say this is because you
could literally see the afghan swarming
the runway as all of this was happening
all of which has driven the washington
post to correctly point out that this is
a disaster area they say this is again
the washington post editorial board
quote this is a moral disaster
unattributable not to the actions of
military and diplomatic personnel but to
mistakes strategic and tactical by mr
biden and his administration correct
the biden administration says the
washington post says they will not be
forgotten plans already are being
developed officials say for continued
efforts to extract people nearly a
hundred nations issued a statement etc
any assurances by the taliban clash with
statements their spokesperson made
during the crisis that the united states
was wrongly inducing afghans to leave
so even the washington post is like yeah
this is just nonsense by the way u.s
citizens are still stranded there they
said no one told them to leave
according to the new york post a
terrified american citizen who was an
interpreter for the us military has said
she's now stranded in afghanistan
because nobody told her the last flights
were leaving on monday
the interpreter was using the pseudonym
for safety she said i just found out
that the last u.s troops left i was just
silent for a while i can't believe no
one told me this is the last fraud the
last flight she says they left us to
whom to those people who wanted to
always kill us
it's heartbreaking i still had hoped
that we would leave
she said she repeatedly attempted to get
through to mercy flights at kabul
detailing how she was instructed to hold
up an umbrella and shout out a code word
but nothing worked to get past the
checkpoints in the thousands trying to
flee
she as if americans couldn't help me
when they were on the ground what the
hell do they expect to do now
she says that she is sheltering 37
people at her house including 19
children two of whom are disabled
so really well done it was a historic
success a historic success
amazing the state department
spokesperson ned price who is basically
the baghdad bob of this operation
he says you know he's asked so you guys
said that there would be other ways for
americans to escape are you aware of any
americans who have left since the united
states abandons in afghanistan a couple
of days ago no answer
did you have a number for have any
americans gotten out since that last
flight i i don't have uh i don't have
data to provide on that front
okay now this is doing some pretty
severe damage to joe biden as well it
should according to civics polls right
so they have polls of presidential
approval in every state
his approval rating
has dropped by 11 points in arizona four
in colorado 11 in florida 13 in georgia
nine in michigan four in minnesota four
in nevada seven in new mexico 12 in
north carolina 12 in pennsylvania 25 in
texas six in virginia and six in
wisconsin
those are really bad numbers for the
presidents of the united states and
heading into 2022 this looks like
wipeout territory for the democrats so
of course they are banking again on
january 6th and the january 6th
commission i just don't think that dog
is going to hunt
there's only one group of people in
power right now there is one man who
made this decision he sits at the head
of the united states government the
decision is disastrous the ramifications
are horrific and he's going to bear the
brunt of the political firestorm that is
to come as well he should
the democrats decided they chose decline
they chose this
is a free willing unnecessary choice
that was made here
americans are still behind enemy lines
those americans are not going to get out
now the hope is that the media will save
them the hope is that the media will
just abandon those people behind enemy
lines and they'll move on to the next
news cycle maybe that's right maybe it
is or maybe a couple weeks from now isis
will chop somebody's head off as an
american citizen and joe biden will be
out front explaining how we're working
with the taliban in order to stop isis
we have to work with the taliban now by
the way that is in fact the new line
from the biden administration
we'll see how popular that one is
all right speaking of which
this is in fact the new line from the
biden administration is that we are
going to be besties with testes with the
taliban it's going to be amazing so
general mark milley who's very concerned
with white rage he's not concerned with
taliban rage so much like they're
they're good they're good guys he's very
concerned with white rage the same
administration that says that you the
law-abiding american citizen cannot have
an ar-15 says we should hand over
probably hundreds of thousands of m4s to
the taliban as well as helicopters and
everything else so i said on the show a
while back that was 83 billion dollars
in u.s military equipment that had been
handed over to the taliban it turns out
that's not right there was a fact check
from the media on this particular issue
it turns out that it is not in fact that
amount
i i'm sorry i apologize it was only tens
of billions of dollars in united states
military equipment so that obviously
makes things much much better but the
good news is we handed them over to
people who are just going to use them
for the best purposes so for example the
taliban has now handed over our weapons
to iran so that's good
i mean at least we're at least we're
using a middleman now when it was obama
he's just sending direct pallets of cash
to the taliban now
they're actually just sending weapons
they're loading them literally onto
trucks and then sending them to iran
according to reporter mario solgam
photos and reports from iranian and
afghan social media show the taliban
have handed us tanks and humvees to iran
below is a photo of humvees being
transported towards iran
things working out real well over there
general mark billy
there's that picture those are uh that's
all the stuff that you paid for and i
paid for
and now it's gonna be wielded by iran
well done just well done general mark
milley he says you know what we have new
friends our friends might be the taliban
i can tell you uh from personal
experience
uh that this is a ruthless group from
the past
and whether or not they change remains
to be seen oh does it
and as far as our dealings with them at
that airfield or in the past year or so
in war you do what you must
in order to reduce risk to mission and
force not what you necessarily want to
do
any possibility of coordination against
isis k with him
it's possible we might be coordinating
with the taliban against isis k so again
this is this bizarre
democrat notion that terrorist groups
never work together and the taliban and
isis k the taliban will have an interest
in working with us against isis k right
that worked out great for the 13 service
people who were murdered
just last week
it's working out great over there it's
not like al qaeda and isis are flooding
into the country it's not like the
reason we went into afghanistan in the
first place is because the taliban had
opened terror had opened its arms to
terror groups but you know maybe we'll
work with them maybe it'll be good
meanwhile what is the taliban doing
they're mocking the united states of
course of course they held a mock
funeral the taliban did for the united
states complete with a a flag-draped
american coffin
you can see the images here there's also
a french flag there as well
and the nato flag it looks like
and and so these set i love the 7th
century barbarians carrying
american-made technology there how many
people there are holding up iphones uh
so you get the british flag the french
flag these are these are new allies guys
they're our best friends and you know
what it's going to be so effective
because remember that airstrike the one
where we sent a drone
missile into a car and uh it may have in
fact just shredded like seven kids
you know that that one so yeah the
taliban is going to provide us excellent
on the ground we have over the rising
capacity right that's what joe biden
says which is more like over the rainbow
capacity but we have over the horizon
capacity which is a nice way of saying
we don't have anybody on ground anywhere
near where we need to hit so we're going
back to the 1998 shoot a missile into a
camel's ass strategy from bill clinton
that had no dire ramifications right i
mean if we just start from that 1998
strategy again and replay history with
the exact same people in the exact same
place
i wonder might there be some
if we think historically did anything
happen after we did that
like you know around september of 2001
or so anyway
the taliban was also parading u.s
military hardware don't worry guys it
wasn't 83 billion dollars in military
hardware there's only like probably 20
30 billion dollars of american military
hardware
glad we could turn that over to them
so that was great by the way the media
who are just doing stenography for the
administration half of them are tweeting
out things like we disabled
some of our military equipment at the
final bases we left oh you mean like the
the last place we left we disabled some
of the military equipment because i'm
noticing not a lot of disabled military
equipment right there and i noticed the
taliban flying around blackhawk
helicopters the other day matt zeller
former cia analyst
who's on cnn and msnbc he says yeah you
know the taliban are new friends they're
going to be
just executing people on mass that's the
next thing to happen
so imagine if they had listened to us
because in some alternate reality they
did and every single one of those
afghans is now here and alive
unfortunately they didn't and so the
reality is is that the taliban have
already begun hunting these people down
i have video evidence of them doing it
of taking people that we were actively
trying to assist
they're waiting to form a new government
before they punish these people but our
fear is that you'll begin to see mass
executions within the next couple of
weeks
yep but don't worry they'll still be our
friends because joe biden needs them to
be our friends for his pr proposal that
he has actually done a masterful job
throughout all of this okay meanwhile on
the covet front uh the the
kind of screaming and screeching is
getting louder and louder and less and
less consistent uh i i it really is kind
of a bizarre thing so why don't we start
with um with joe rogan so joe rogan of
course it was announced that he got
coveted you know that is not a that is
not a particularly big story you know
why it's not a story because like
hundreds of thousands of people have
coveted right now the question is how
many people are getting super sick and
dying from it but rogan is of course in
the category of people who did not
vaccinate and therefore are morally
bereft according to the left now here's
my view on this i disagree with joe i
think you should have taken the vaccine
i took the vaccine
i think the risk factors from coven are
significantly higher than the risk
factors from the actual vaccine but joe
disagrees he's a free human being and
he's capable of making those decisions
however what the media have decided to
do
is they've decided to mock rogan this is
the way that it works right if you are a
democrat and you get coveted that's just
a tragedy an unavoidable tragedy if
you're a republican or a non-democrat or
if you didn't take the vaccine and you
get covered then we'll get to mock and
laugh at you which is a really
interesting standard morally speaking
because it turns out that people get
health conditions on a routine basis
that they could have avoided have they
made different choices i wonder if we're
now going to apply the same logic to
people who have stds for example
like if you get an std which you could
have avoided because you didn't have to
put your thing there uh then are we now
going to just mock and laugh at you or
having the std or maybe we should do
what don lemon suggests which is that if
you're unbacked don lemon says if you're
unvaccinated we just should not have
hospitals care for you you shouldn't go
to the hospital
if you're not going to get vaccinated
you don't want a social distance you
don't want to wear a mask then maybe you
don't want to go to the hospital when
you get sick i know that sounds harsh
but you're taking up the space for
people who are doing things the right
way
yeah so again as i've said before i'm
looking forward to that logic being
extended to all sorts of avoidable
health conditions that people don't take
mitigation measures with regard to so
for example if you get heart disease
because you've been fat for 40 years and
your doctor has told you for 40 years
that you should lose some weight and
stop eating
cheese every single day of your life and
then you get a heart clog you get an
arterial clog maybe you should do it don
lemon says you just don't go to the
hospital anymore i mean that's the way
that this works now right you make a
different decision than john woman would
make
and then presumably you have to bear the
welcome to libertarian land don lemon
it's it's really fascinating to see you
here i did not i never expected that i'm
i'm looking forward as i say to this
being applied to all sorts of sexually
transmitted diseases which are
completely avoidable if you just don't
put that thing there and um and yeah
we'll see how that works out for you um
also
the media have decided they're doing
this routine with regard to brogan
because rogan is very popular and he's
very bad because joe rogan has people
like me on his show sometimes so this
means that he's a bad man joe rogan
when he's very rich bad man who's rich
and bad
and this means that joe rogan who
announced that he had been taking things
like monoclonal antibodies which by the
way are highly effective and then he
said that he had also been taking
prednisone
which is a a widely accepted steroid
treatment
and then he also said that he had taken
a vitamin drip as well as ivermectin
okay so what you've heard from the media
is it is a horse deworming drug
right this is what you keep hearing it's
it's for horse it's for animal dewarming
now ivermectin could be used to deworm
horses sure
also that's really an inapt and
inaccurate description of what
ivermectin is
it's really it's sort of like when they
were describing hydroxychloroquine as a
fish tank cleaner remember they kept
saying this it's the same thing as a
fish tank cleaner and then some idiot
went and used fish tank cleaner to try
and allegedly kill her husband
and then the mirror like this is because
of trump telling people to take fish
tank cleaner
so now they keep calling it a horse drug
and so people who are interested in the
possible impact of ivermectin
are listening to the media and they're
actually going out and trying to get
like dosages of horse drugs
because the media are just idiotic and
they're liars here's what ivermectin
actually is okay this is from forbes
forbes magazine
in october of 2015.
nobel prize-winning drug ivermectin may
fight malaria
resurrecting old drugs for unmet medical
needs known more formally as drug
repurposing was an important message in
the nobel prize for medicine earlier
this month it came up today too with the
intriguing study showing that the
anti-parasitic drug ivermectin is an
antiparasitic appears promising for
disrupting malaria transmission
this new finding was presented today at
the american society of tropical
medicine and hygiene annual meeting by
researchers from colorado state
university ivermectin has been used for
decades given once per year as part of
the mass drug administration programs to
reduce the disabling worm infections
enco circa cerciosis which causes river
blindness and filariasis the the cause
of the hugely swollen legs elephant
elephant titus
merc has generously donated the entire
supply of the drug in sub-saharan africa
each year a deadly malaria parasite
kills 584 000 people per year most of
them kids
they started using ivermectin for the
kids
and uh apparently there was a serious
reduction in childhood malaria episodes
in these particular villages
okay so here is the thing
it can be used to deworm
also
it has been used for many other purposes
and the nobel prize was awarded to
researchers researchers in iphorbectin
some of whom have suggested that this
thing might be effective against colvid
so i have no view on ivermectin because
i've seen no studies on the efficacy of
ivermectin for use against covet i can
tell you it is deeply inaccurate for the
media to continue just saying that joe
rogan and company are taking horse
de-worming drugs for no apparent reason
and for no scientist and no scientist
like
guys you did the same thing with
hydroxychloroquine it turned out that
that might have had an impact especially
if taken early on
it's it's amazing to watch the media
shift in real time on what works and
what doesn't based completely on
politics like completely on politics you
remember monoclonal antibodies became
bad the moment that ron desantis
mentioned them hydroxychloroquine became
bad the moment trump mentioned it and
ivermectin became bad the moment that
joe rogan started taking it
that is the way all of this works
meanwhile they'll continue to
idiotically scare the hell out of people
who are already vaccinated again the
goal here is just do what the government
wants just do what they want even if
it's completely conflicting so you have
an entire piece in the washington post
talking about how a breakthrough case of
covid can still really be bad it can be
really bad now the reality breakthrough
cases of covet are extremely rare in
terms of having significant symptoms
you can get a breakthrough case of cove
but it usually manifests as a flu or a
like a very mild flu or a cold
but there's an entire long piece in the
washington post about a person named
andrew kinsey who was vaccinated
for nearly a week after getting a
breakthrough case kinsey felt like he'd
been run over by a truck he struggled to
walk a few steps and to stay awake
through episodes of the tv show doomsday
preppers he returned to work last monday
as a corporate litigator but needs
midday naps
he says it's important for people to
know that what they picture in their
head of a bad cold isn't necessarily
what will happen even if they get a mild
course kinsey and other vaccinated
people who develop breakthrough cases of
covet 19 are learning a mild case may
not seem so mild to the person enduring
the infection
those cases can be modest as a few days
of sniffles but in other circumstances
can spawn debilitating headaches and
fatigue symptoms can persist longer than
the usual cold
now um i perused this entire article
and what i noticed is that there is
literally
no data with regard to how many people
are reporting like super serious
symptoms also
if you get a really bad flu there are no
articles about that instead it's just a
bunch of anecdotal stuff about how
people have gotten sick and they're
feeling sick and stuff which is true of
the flu every single year and it is not
a public health issue
and the media's main narrative seems to
be do whatever
you are told and we're not going to
present data to tell you why you should
do what you're told you just need to do
what you're told
and then we'll sort of
we'll just cherry-pick data to to push a
particular regimen of a course of action
so for example this there's a big
bangladesh study that was that was
touted yesterday
this big bangladesh study said yesterday
was a they followed like 360 people in
bangladesh they had different villages
that were assigned masks and not
assigned masks and what the what the
study found is that where there were
mask mandates there tended to be social
distancing where there was social
distancing there tended to be a drop in
the virus they said that surgical masks
seemed to make more of a difference than
cloth masks although there was some
pretty
yeah like some difference not not a huge
difference but some difference okay then
they said that there was a pretty
significant decrease in terms of the
effect on symptomatic sero-prevalence by
age group meaning symptomatic covet by
age group if you're above the age of 60
there's about a 35 percent decrease in
your symptomatic covid attainment if you
were in a village that had a surgical
mask mandate and if you're 50 to 60 same
thing right there is a serious decrease
like 23 decrease what's weird about this
particular study is it shows no
statistically significant decrease in
the attainment of symptomatic covid
if you were below the age of 50.
none
and now people are going to be using
this study to say that children need to
mask no evidence from the study children
need to ask they're going to be saying
from this study that masked mandates
generally work which of course ignores
the fact that country-wide mass mandates
really don't and we've not seen any
significant evidence that country-wide
mass mandates are particularly effective
so they're going to pick the data
meaning that the upper age brackets here
were helped by a mass mandate that that
is not particularly shocking and those
are the people most vulnerable now what
do you do in a country like the united
states where the vast majority of people
60 and up are vaccinated okay that's a
way better protection than masking we
know this for a fact
so what the hell are we talking about
and yet this is going to be big news
masking works tell people to mask mask
mandates mass mandates or alternatively
if you can get vaccinated masks are now
not relevant why are we talking about
masking in the end and the answer is
it's just endless
it's endless we're in the endless
pandemic and because we're in the
endless pandemic
we have to continue talking about
measures like masking that are way less
effective than vaccines and in order to
push that we have to have articles in
the washington post about how even if
you're vaccinated you might get a bad
mean case of covid and it might feel
like the flu and you might feel yucky
afterward for a while
and by the way that happens with
diseases all the time when i was younger
i had a case of salmonella i felt crappy
for like a year
that is not rare
but the idea here again is that you must
they're going to offer you all sorts of
conflicting information then out from
the clouds will stop anthony fauci and
you must listen to anthony fauci or
you're anti the science meanwhile we
will tell you that ivermectin is only
used for horse deworming we will tell
you that even if you're vaccinated you
might get a really bad case of covid we
won't give you any stats to back that up
we'll tell you without any evidence
whatsoever that it is mandatory that
you've accident that you mask your
three-year-old child with a cloth mask
in the middle of delta by the way this
study here was not done with regard to
delta the study was done with regard to
the original variant delta has 300 times
the viral load we'd love to see the
stats on how effective surgical masks
are with regard to a virus that has 300
times the viral load that the original
virus had
you're not going to see any of that
you're just going to see the headlines
and so you end up with people acting
irrationally and people acting in in
great fear for their lives when this is
not necessary i mean i know lots of
people who are like this on the one what
you end up with is a complete breakdown
between two groups one people who are
utterly paranoid about every single
little thing and people who think all of
it's bull crap and they're just gonna
take their chances that's what you're
seeing society break down into right
people who are like i'm triple vaxxed
right i'm double vaxxed i'm getting i'm
getting a booster and i still
will not go to a place where somebody
could have a virus including a child
because who knows i could die it could
be me i could be the one
we're turning into a society of those
people versus the people who are like
all these people are crazy i'm not
taking anything i'm taking my chances
even though i'm 65 and fat
it's like well you know what would have
been great is if the institutions of our
society had not completely destroyed
their own credibility
by declaring themselves so elite that
they didn't have to actually by telling
platonic laws that were designed to
protect the people from themselves
because all you end up with is people
who believe they are part of the
platonic lying group and therefore have
to mask up it as a model to everybody
else and people who say you lied to me
why would i possibly trust you ever ever
again
alrighty we've reached the end of
today's show but we'll back here later
today with an additional hour of content
coming up soon is the matt wall show
airing at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to
check it out over at dailywire.com i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crans the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show